67 years three dozen movies the godzilla
franchise has had some of the highest
highs and lowest lows in monster cinema
history
keep watching to know which movies to
include in your next godzilla marathon
the worst of the worst is undoubtedly
godzilla not the original but the
american-made mess that somehow made it
into theaters in 1998. director roland
emmerich's take on the classic kaiju
tried really hard to do some cool stuff
with the unique story and modern special
effects the laughable cgi prevented it
from having the punch producers had
hoped for this version of godzilla is
barely seen as it hides among buildings
in new york because if there's anything
godzilla is known for it's hiding that
and squeezing through subway tunnels for
some reason the closest thing the film
has to a saving grace is matthew
broderick but even ferris bueller
himself can't save this movie from being
a complete blunder
most fans would agree that the 1998
godzilla has had a negative impact on
the franchise as a whole oh damn uh
that is a negative impact i repeat that
is a negative impact
they gave it their best shot but netflix
definitely missed the mark when they put
out their run of animated godzilla
movies godzilla planet of the monsters
godzilla city on the edge of battle and
godzilla the planet eater aren't as
outrageously out of place in the
godzilla canon as the 1998 film but
they're certainly not quite outstanding
enough to earn individual spots on this
list
this trilogy tries desperately to
compensate for a lack of compelling
story with vibrant animation but the
drama just isn't there thanks to a lack
of memorable characters
this series gives a look at a
post-apocalyptic future earth where
humans have traveled into space to
escape godzilla and other monsters
continuous destruction
the concept is compelling and could have
made for a fantastic new take on the
godzilla mythos but the execution
doesn't exactly stick the landing
godzilla vs mega gears is another
example of a film that attempted to do
something unique within the godzilla
universe but came out lukewarm at best
unlike the hulking beasts that godzilla
is typically known for fighting the mega
new lawns featured in this entry in the
millennium series are more like a swarm
of annoying mosquitoes it's only at the
end of the movie when godzilla faces off
with the mega nullan queen megaguiris
the things actually start to get excited
the plot is mediocre at best reworking
the millennium era godzilla into its own
being while somehow managing to stay
disconnected from every film that came
before it
add that to the infamously bad acting
from the human characters and you get
one of many misguided attempts to
further the franchise after the y2k
scare
most viewers would agree that godzilla's
revenge also known as all monsters
attack isn't the worst of films but it's
a tedious watch and among the most
skippable entries in the franchise
godzilla's revenge was geared towards
small children in an attempt to find new
demographics for a declining franchise
unsurprisingly this didn't set well with
adults the film is from the perspective
of a bullied child watching poorly cut
together stock fights taken directly
from earlier better godzilla movies it
sold well as a late 60s kid movie but it
was also a sign of the dark times ahead
for the godzilla franchise
stock monster fights aren't awful on
their own though so no one will blame
you for watching this oddly edited
string of them
with ibera horror of the deep we're
moving away from the truly disliked
films and getting into mixed reviews
territory
the main drawback of this film is how
different it is than the more
traditional godzilla movies most notably
by not including much of godzilla at all
until the end the plot is pretty decent
though
a man loses his brother at sea learns
from a mystic that he might still be
alive and heads out on a stolen sailboat
to find him only to run into a nasty
oversized lobster called ibira godzilla
snoozes for a while before finally doing
his thing defeating the crustacean by
ripping its claws off with an assist
from mothra the effects and quality
hadn't gotten any better than the
earliest films but that's one of the
things fans of ibira like about it it's
just the major lack of godzilla that
really drives this movie down
godzilla tokyo sos is a bit confusing
the plot involves mothra showing up and
telling everybody they need to get the
original godzilla's bones out of mecca
godzilla and lay them to rest because
it's disrespectful to use a dead
lizard's bones to raise a new monster
then godzilla shows up not the original
godzilla who is now inside mechagodzilla
but a second newer godzilla and if
that's not weird enough mothra ends up
helping mecha godzilla for some reason
instead of going through with
dismantling the mechanical beast tokyo
sos definitely wasn't as bad as some of
the films that preceded it but it's
generally considered to be a lazy
attempt by the producers of the
millennium films to keep up with the old
rate of production
terror of mechagodzilla was the last
godzilla film in what many considered to
be the tail end of a declining franchise
at least before its resurrection in
1984.
by this point godzilla movies had
largely moved away from horror fair and
into the realm of bizarre creations
seemingly conjured from the mind of a
six-year-old
terror of mechagodzilla bombed at the
box office but it has its defenders most
of the love for this movie can be traced
to the return of veteran director ishiro
honda the man behind the original 1954
godzilla and several of its sequels
honda didn't save the movie entirely but
he did manage to give it the feel of a
godzilla flick of decades past
terror of mechagodzilla was honda's
final directorial effort and far from
his best contribution to the franchise
but it was clear that his passion for
the monster had never faded even after
21 years
if rotten tomatoes scoring system is to
be trusted then godzilla final wars is
as mediocre as a movie can be weighing
in at a perfect 50 percent
it's part of the millennium era in which
overarching narrative was largely
abandoned in favor of pure spectacle and
bizarre twists final wars was certainly
unique but that wasn't necessarily a
good thing the film might be hit or miss
but it sure is fun a trove of classic
monsters and aliens descends on the
earth leaving godzilla to save the day
classic stylings with modern effects
bring the action to life but the acting
of the human characters is bad enough to
ruin any suspension of disbelief
godzilla against mechagodzilla is
another mostly unremarkable film from
the millennium era but it distinguishes
itself by being the first movie in the
franchise in which women are truly
essential to the narrative kaiju aren't
just for boys after all the film also
had a more progressive and diverse cast
of characters which the franchise had
been trending towards since the 90s the
mechagodzilla suit featured in this film
is polarizing among fans some think the
newer design is a worthy evolution while
others seem to think it should have kept
its classic look either way you see it
you'll probably agree the plot is on the
weird side the old godzilla is dead a
new godzilla has risen to take the
former's place and now the old
godzilla's bones are used to create the
mechagodzilla cyborg
at least it's still easier to follow
than its direct sequel godzilla tokyo
sos
godzilla vs megalon may not have wowed
critics past or present but fans
certainly seem to prefer it over most of
the films of the millennium era this
film is still a versus title from the
downturned showa era of the franchise
but it was better than most of the time
even though it was being aggressively
marketed toward children in a desperate
bid to keep the rubber suit filled
although franchise revenues were
constantly dwindling at the time
godzilla vs megalon made relatively
decent money at the box office much of
its success was thanks to efficient
marketing involving the new character
jet jaguar whose design was the result
of a fan contest that touhou held the
previous year
thankfully godzilla vs megalon actually
feels like a godzilla film and for that
it earned itself a place at number 25.
in a confusing twist of fate some people
were actually disappointed that godzilla
2000 wasn't a direct sequel to the 1998
american version
for the majority of fans however it was
a breath of fresh air in comparison
godzilla 2000 had many of the stylings
of the older films giving viewers the
version of the king of monsters they
feared had been lost to the new world of
computer generated imogen
even though there's still plenty of bad
cgi to behold
the story is also off for some reason
godzilla 2000 was disconnected from all
previous godzilla films and raised
enough questions about continuity to
leave anyone familiar with the series
with a lingering sense of confusion all
in all though it was a decent movie that
blended modern animatronics with a suit
we were pleased to see hadn't yet made
it to the metaphorical trash
mechagodzilla has most recently been
seen stopping godzilla from destroying
cities but he wasn't always written that
way in godzilla vs mechagodzilla the
robotic titan's first appearance in the
franchise mechagodzilla is a robot sent
by aliens to destroy japan naturally
it's up to godzilla proper to save the
day godzilla vs mecca godzilla gave us
one of godzilla's most iconic foes and
for that fans can't thank it enough
we're also gifted with the so bad it's
good guardian monster king caesar
that being said it wasn't the best movie
it could have been the film suffers from
some pacing issues and features some
truly bizarre musical choices it's also
gorier than any of the previous entries
in the franchise which is a plus for
some and a minus for others
when it comes to godzilla vs space
godzilla most fans have one of two
opinions either it's one of the best
godzilla films they've ever seen
or it's fairly worth watching
if you're into godzilla because you like
watching big lizards destroy things then
you'll probably enjoy this movie after
all you get two godzilla's for the price
of one
space godzilla is believed to be a clone
of the original lizard but with several
enhancements most notably those massive
crystal spikes growing out of his back
there's some fun tension between space
godzilla and godzilla jr too reminiscent
of an abandoned child taking out his
parental qualms on the sibling who got
all the attention outside of that though
the movie isn't very good the psychic
subplot continues from the previous
films but it doesn't have much impact on
anything that actually happens the
special effects are also lacking not
quite on par with the other heisei era
films
godzilla vs mechagodzilla 2 scored
pretty high with critics ending up with
an impressive rotten tomato score of 83
percent
not all fans would agree with that
assessment however the website's
audience ranking is hovering just above
70
which feels more in line with the fun
factor of this film
mechagodzilla is built from the remains
of mecca king ghidorah and this time is
meant to be humanity's savior
the movie also introduces godzilla
junior not manila the babyface creature
past but a younger version of godzilla
that grows up to be half as big yet just
as terrifying the only issue fans really
seem to have with the film is the
updated mechagodzilla design that lacks
some of its classic elements such as the
iconic finger
rockets while mothra is often thrown
into godzilla movies just because fans
like the character she doesn't just show
up for no reason in godzilla and mothra
the battle for earth
here mothra takes center stage as the
benevolent protector of earth godzilla
rampages batra falls from the sky to
teach the world a lesson and mothra
joins in the fight to stop godzilla
eventually sealing him under the sea
then mothra takes off to tour the
universe for some reason or another the
effects in this movie are pretty great
mothra looks cooler than ever before
with bigger wings and better coloring
there really aren't too many negatives
about this movie but there aren't many
highlights either it's a good godzilla
film but nothing groundbreaking
the battle between king kong and
godzilla in whatever form it might take
is probably the most iconic of all the
kaiju fights in the genre
the warm-blooded primate versus the sea
dwelling reptile is a match-up that
can't be missed it's so popular in fact
that a remake was released in 2021 and
it's also the reason this movie made it
this far on the list unfortunately
1962's king kong vs godzilla is
considered a bit of a blemish on the
series among hardcore fans not because
it wasn't a good movie but because it's
a symbol of when godzilla transitioned
from existentially terrifying to silly
and family friendly if you haven't yet
seen the modern reboot you should
definitely pop this in the vcr first and
witness the original battle between the
world's two most beloved monsters
critics weren't too pleased with
godzilla's most recent solo outing
godzilla king of the monsters many cite
the plot mechanics as tricky and hard to
follow while others claimed the
storytelling was worthless and couldn't
be saved
however many fans would be quick to
disagree sure the plot and story are
sub-optimal but the action and
spectacular effects drove audience
reviews far into the realm of favorable
there's no man in a rubber suit so it
doesn't offer much in the way of cheesy
classic appeal but it's undeniably an
entertaining two hours godzilla king of
the monsters features plenty of our
favorite titans such as mothra rodin and
the magnificent three-headed menace king
ghidorah all looking more life-like than
ever it's a testament to the lasting
legacy that godzilla has cultivated over
the years
in an era where the godzilla franchise
had moved toward younger audiences
it was rare to see an installment that
pandered to the adult crowd the way the
early horror type entries did
godzilla vs gigan was pretty much the
only godzilla movie from the 70s that
adults could say was made for them the
film starts out almost like jurassic
park a group of business owners want to
summon the world's most fearsome
monsters for their own game
as you'd assume this doesn't work out
but not in the way you'd think the
businessmen are actually aliens trying
to take over earth by calling on gigan
and king ghidorah to wreak havoc on the
world the film's highlight is a
two-on-two fight with godzilla and
anguirus battling the two destroyers
godzilla vs gigan is definitely worth
watching if you have the time but like
the others up to this point it probably
won't be your favorite
one of the aspects of the godzilla
franchise that made it such a beast over
half a century ago is the social
commentary with which it packs its best
films this started with the original and
has been present on occasion ever since
often those that break this precedent
are simply action for action's sake with
no other redeeming qualities made solely
to entertain and nothing else
godzilla vs hedorah however has plenty
to say the plot revolves around the
pollution that plagues the earth which
makes it the perfect target for the smog
sucking monster to drop in from space
and muck around
fortunately for everyone else godzilla
saves the day and the world receives a
grim reminder of the consequences of
their less than green practices
the film commonly referred to as
invasion of astral monster has gone by
three different names depending on date
and location
when you see someone mention godzilla vs
astro monster or godzilla vs monster
zero they're talking about the same
movie other than that minor confusion
which doesn't really factor into the
quality of the feature it's pretty good
since the film is a direct sequel to
ghidorah the three-headed monster the
fan favorite character comes back for a
second helping the movie is enjoyable
but not quite as good as the first
either of these ghidorah movies could
have done without the other since they
have basically the same story
regardless of whatever name you call it
invasion of astro monster is perfectly
watchable even if it doesn't quite match
up to ghidorah's previous outing in
order to really appreciate the heisei
era of the godzilla franchise and take
in all the fun the 80s and 90s entries
have to offer it's best to view them as
a similar yet separate string of films
if you do you'll likely enjoy godzilla
vs biollante since it's the epitome of
this age some of godzilla cells have
been recovered from a volcano and
different groups have different ideas
for what to do with them naturally this
causes a fight and the cells ultimately
land in the hands of the japanese
military where they are spliced with
rose dna and mutate into the creature
known as biollante
naturally you can guess who biolante
ends up in a big kaiju battle against
godzilla vs biollante has plot action
and of course rubber suits making it a
darn good film as far as godzilla
himself is concerned
as for the acting and character
development they're far from perfect to
put it kindly
the first godzilla movie of the 2020s is
certainly a film worth seeing with some
of the best special effects in cgi that
money can buy some purists might not
enjoy the film's sleek hollywood look
but it's undeniable that godzilla vs
kong features some of the most
impressive visuals the franchise has to
offer
unfortunately the movie falls a little
flat when it comes to character
development and drama even though kong
seems to change sizes depending on
what's happening in the film the
exciting action and visual direction
overshadow any narrative flaws if you
want to see the world's two most famous
kaiju duke it out and stunning 4k
resolution this is the movie to watch
king ghidorah makes any godzilla movie
worth watching even if said films aren't
cinematic masterpieces when it comes to
fun monstery goodness king ghidorah's
three heads are hard to beat as such
godzilla vs king ghidorah is a
delightfully cheesy b-movie that exists
purely to entertain especially if you
watch the english dub it's a dinosaur a
gigantic dinosaurs attacking our boys
despite a bizarre time travel storyline
godzilla vs king ghidorah succeeds
through delightful special effects and
epic monster designs there's two boss
fights for the price of one as
godzilla's fight against ghidorah is
followed up with an epic battle against
mecca king ghidorah an enhanced version
of the monster teleported in from the
23rd century
this is the perfect godzilla film for a
midnight movie with a couple of friends
and lots of popcorn
some super fans may see this particular
film as problematic within the godzilla
canon but it's an important piece of the
franchise's history
son of godzilla is the first time we
well meet the son of godzilla this
reptilian child a clumsy troublemaker
named manila is a walking embodiment of
the light-hearted humor the series was
shifting toward at the time
in this first appearance manila has to
help godzilla defeat a giant spider
called kumonga
many view the inclusion of manila as an
even further push in the childish
direction and it honestly was but that
doesn't make son of godzilla any less of
a classic with the franchise having been
built on small sets with big rubber
suits from the very beginning the
classics are what it's all about after
all
destroy all monsters is generally
considered the last good godzilla film
before the franchise went into its 70s
slump
the movie is exceedingly fun if not
chaotic and packs a heavy punch it has
the largest brawl out of any godzilla
film bringing in 11 of the classic
creatures to duke it out not all these
monsters get the luxury of full screen
time with some only having short cameos
but that doesn't stop the film's final
battle from feeling like a tokusatsu
version of avengers end game viewers
have to wade through the movie's slow
start to get to the action but every
ounce of patience is worth the wait it's
the last remnant of the good old days
going out with a bang you'll definitely
want to watch this particular film with
subtitles though the english dubbing is
pretty awful and hard to follow
other than the name being an absolute
mouthful godzilla mothra and king
ghidorah giant monster's all-out attack
is an all-around fantastic film and is
easily the best at the millennium era
fortunately this movie doesn't feel like
an early 21st century garbage sheep like
most of the others from the time instead
we get the man in the green rubber suit
and everything godzilla is back with a
vengeance infused with the restless
spirits of world war ii veterans and
ready to destroy japan in retaliation
for its crimes that is until three
powerful guardians come to the country's
aid baragon mothra and king ghidorah
even without these fan favorites on
screen the movie spirit is the political
commentary of godzilla's past and for
that it weighs in at number nine the top
10 is highly competitive and godzilla vs
destoroyah is no lightweight in fact
it's the only godzilla movie to score a
perfect 100 on rotten tomatoes the movie
was the finale of the heisei series and
brought the era to a banging halt
godzilla was built up over the course of
a decade so he could meet his end in the
final moments of this film the finale to
the heisei era was originally planned to
involve godzilla dueling with the ghost
of the 1954 godzilla which definitely
would have been a showdown to remember
instead we got godzilla having a literal
nuclear meltdown while looking like he
needs the world's largest toms that's
not to say the film isn't absolutely
fantastic it is and it's definitely
worth checking out
the year was 1984 and the godzilla
franchise had been sitting near death on
a 9-year hiatus
the goofiness of the showa era had put a
lot of people off and if the big guy was
going to grace the screen once more the
film would have to be exceptional
sure enough it was
the nuclear lizard rose from the sea
once again in the return of godzilla the
first film of the heisei era brought the
world's favorite kaiju back to its roots
the plot made heavy commentary on the
cold war tensions that had been weighing
the world down for years leading up to
the film returning godzilla to a mature
less childlike format not everyone was
as happy as they should have been to see
the big man back however the franchise
had laid dormant for years and there
were some cynics who believed it should
have stayed that way most godzilla fans
particularly those in japan were more
than happy to see the radioactive menace
make his grand return to the silver
screen
there's no denying ghidorah the
three-headed monster has flaws when it
comes to production quality and its
stature is more a product of nostalgia
than anything else so why is it so high
on this list well no other movie in the
franchise introduced king ghidorah the
three-headed creature is one of the most
powerful and awesome monsters in the
franchise not just a city destroyer but
a potentially world-ending threat and
for that alone this movie shines
that's not to say the film doesn't have
other premium qualities of course as
opposed to the more human-like beasts
they'd come to expect ghidorah gave fans
a truly monstrous monster
as for the human characters they are
surprisingly well developed and helped
weave humor effortlessly throughout the
tension ghidorah the three-headed
monster earned its spot at number six
and it wasn't given lightly
godzilla raids again was the first
godzilla sequel released just one year
after the original
it proved to be a stunning film in its
own right with the ferocity in its
choreography that other kaiju pictures
of the day lacked this was the first
godzilla film to pit the king of
monsters against another creature of its
size specifically the irradiated
dinosaur anguirus ultimately the spiked
creature isn't powerful enough to take
godzilla down leaving it up to the
humans to save the day once again
for all of its high points godzilla
raids again has its faults when it comes
to plot most notably its erasure of
godzilla's death at the end of the first
movie regardless its importance to the
growth of the franchise truly can't be
understated
despite what some purists might say
entertainment is just as important as
historical and intellectual value when
it comes to ranking kaiju movies and the
2014 godzilla was just about as
entertaining as they come nobody
expected an american godzilla film with
advanced special effects to work 1998
killed that idea for us but this movie
showed us that one bad apple doesn't
ruin a bunch of awesome giant monsters
beating the crap out of each other the
way this movie is shot has a lot to do
with its quality
instead of watching monsters rampage in
the distance the 2014 film gave viewers
a point of view that made us feel like
we were right there looking up at the
carnage what are you doing
i have to see this
the progression withholds details in
just the right amount showing us bits
and pieces until we're burdened by the
crushing weight of a sci-fi horror the
movie was masterfully done in just about
every way we just wish we could have
seen a little more brian cranston
the best godzilla movie of the 21st
century shin godzilla is not just one of
the most entertaining movies about the
giant lizard but also a biting piece of
political satire in this movie which
takes place in an entirely separate
continuity from every other godzilla
film
not only is godzilla upset about being
woken up from his decades-long nap but
he's also punishing japan and
retaliation for the fukushima disaster
and humanity's generally irresponsible
use of nuclear power the movie spends a
lot of time inside bureaucratic meetings
in which the japanese government tries
to manage the crisis but that never
detracts at all from the film's power
shin godzilla embodies the soul of
godzilla that seemed to have been lost
in the millennium era's need for
mindless action
much of shin godzilla's success can be
attributed to the masterful direction of
hideaki anno the creator of the iconic
anime series neon genesis evangelion who
presents a disturbing version of
godzilla unlike any other put to screen
even though mothra made her first
appearance in the 1961 film of the same
name mothra vs godzilla marked the first
of many times the giant insect would
face the giant lizard in battle mothra
vs godzilla is generally considered the
greatest godzilla installment from its
decade not to mention the second best in
the entire series comedic overtones mesh
with a serious storyline to bring us the
underdog fight of a lifetime godzilla is
a powerhouse bent on raising hell while
mothra is forced to dig deep and use
more strength than ever before to save
japan from his destructive rampage
it's a classic story of overcoming evil
but with two giant monsters and all the
cutting-edge effects the early 60s could
muster the human storyline isn't quite
as good but that's something godzilla
fans have come to expect over the years
you're probably not surprised to see the
first ever godzilla movie at the top of
the list and why would you be ishiro
honda's godzilla is the film that
sparked more than 65 years of sequels
reboots and series based on the king of
monsters regardless of its follow-ups
however the very first godzilla was a
powerful piece raised high on its own
merit movie critic roger ebert called
godzilla quote the fahrenheit 911 of its
time
and for good reason
godzilla was created as a response to
american radiation testing in pacific
waters as well as the lasting effects of
the nuclear bombs dropped on hiroshima
and nagasaki in 1945
the movie was a warning about nuclear
technology in the hands of human beings
and the destructive force that such a
power could have if used incorrectly
sure the movie can look a bit silly at
times as many sci-fi movies from the 50s
do
but its concept is utterly brilliant
setting a precedent for other godzilla
stories to speak out about human folly
in all its forms
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movie monsters are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]